und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend da
der Krieg nur auf ukrainischen Boden
stattfindet musste Vladimir Putin nicht
fürchten dass seine Zivilbevölkerung
ebenfalls hungert friert und ausgebombt
wird den Horror des Krieges bekommen auf
russischer Seite nur seine Soldaten
unmittelbar zu spüren die haben
allerdings Angehörige vor allem haben
sie Mütter die in Russland
traditionsreiche eigene Organisationen
unterhalten mehr als 80.000 russische
Soldaten sollen bereits gefallen oder
verwundet sein oder als vermisst gelten
hinzu kommen die vielen Berichte wie
grausam sie von der eigenen Armee
behandelt werden das Putin wurde bewusst
ist dass das für ihn zum Problem werden
könnte zeigt sich an der
Propaganda-Veranstaltung die ihr heute
abhielt Christiane Hoffmann berichtet
fürsorglicher Landesvater gibt sich
russlands Präsident Putin beim Treffen
mit Soldaten Müttern er spricht von
Respekt und Bewunderung für Mütter und
Ehefrauen doch schnell ist klar das
Treffen ist für die Propaganda wohl
inszeniert die Frauen putinar und Hand
verlesen keine vor ihnen gehöre einer
der Organisationen für Soldaten Mütter
an kritisiert eine der Gründerinnen
diese Frauen waren von der Volksfront
waren Abgeordnete das war ein
vereinbartes treffen das war wieder ein
Dialog nur für sie selbst die Volksfront
und ihren Anführer Putin
sichtlich enttäuscht ist sie denn viele
Ehefrauen und Mütter der 300.000
eingezogenen Soldaten wollen seit Wochen
wissen wie es den Männern geht über
Videos in den sozialen Netzwerken
weissen sie auf die schlechte
Ausstattung mangelnde Ausbildung und
viele Fehler bei der Einberufung hin in
der Stadt Kurs im Südwesten russ
versammeln sich sogar einige in der
Stadtverwaltung Berichten aus Gesprächen
mit ihren Männern verlangen dass sie
zurückkommen dürfen
sie werden in die vorderste Front
gestellt sie werden zusammengezogen und
dann direkt hingebracht wenn sie nicht
zurückkommen dann holen Sie die nächsten
klar wird auch geholfen wird hier nicht
auch diese von den Ukrainern gefangen
genommenen Soldaten berichten vom
Einsatz an vorderster Front drei Tage
hätten sie nichts gegessen die
Kommandeure seien verschwunden niemand
habe sie informiert andere Soldaten
hätten sich geweigert an die Front
zurückzukehren seinen Keller verließe
wie diese gesperrt worden und mit dem
Tod bedroht worden hat Astra ein
Netzwerk unabhängiger Journalisten
recherchiert und mit Angehörigen
gesprochen
einem Soldaten hatte man versprochen
dass er nur als Wachmann eingesetzt
werde doch dann wurde er trotzdem an die
Front geschickt er hat abgelehnt und
sich beschwert
also die sind weder einsatzbereit sonst
sind die ausgerüstet das ist
Kanonenfutter das sind die Front
geschickt wird das ist Menschenmasse die
sozusagen falsch Angriff erfolgen Wellen
darstellen sollen aber die werden keinen
entscheidenden Beitrag zur Kampfkraft
der russischen Armee in der Ukraine
leisten und so tragen sie immer mehr
Tote zu Grabe in einem mit
faschistischer Propaganda begründeten
Krieg die Welt erscheint hier verkehrt
den Opfern der ukrainischen Aggression
steht auf dem Mann mal im Don Bass wir
vergessen nicht und wir verzeihen nicht
zynischer auch gegenüber den Frauen der
getöteten Soldaten kann es nicht sein
bleiben wir noch beim Leben in
Diktaturen China kämpft gerade gegen
eine neue kovet-welle man hätte ja
vielleicht annehmen können dass die
chinesische Führung die Pandemie
leichter bekämpft bekommt als
Demokratien lange Zeit hat sie genau
damit auch sich gebrüstet sie schütze
ihre Bevölkerung besser das Problem ist
nur sie kommt aus der Endlosschleife
ihrer lockdown-politik nicht mehr heraus
sie das nicht geschafft wenigstens den
älteren Teil ihrer milliardenbevölkerung
so ausreichend zu impfen dass sie eine
Lockerung riskieren kann und so handelt
sie sich weiter von einem Ausbruch zum
nächsten mit Zwangsmaßnahmen die fatale
wirtschaftliche Folgen haben und von der
Bevölkerung immer weniger akzeptiert
werden Miriam Steiner berichtet
Superman seinen Spitznamen verdankt
dieser Mann in tongqing im Süden Chinas
einerseits seinem Rucksack mit dem Logo
des Comic-Helden
andererseits spricht er aus was viele
denken und sich nicht zusagen trauen
[Musik]
es gibt nur eine Krankheit auf der Welt
die heißt keine Freiheit und Armut wir
haben jetzt beide und wir mögen uns
immer noch ab mit dieser kleinen
Erkältung wisst ihr warum weil die
Behörden etwas Falsches gemacht haben
und jetzt müssen sie weitermachen sonst
müssten sie zugeben dass es falsch ist
und müssten dafür Verantwortung
übernehmen
[Musik]
China erlebt eine neue corona-welle und
die Führung hält stur an ihrer
null-kovic-strategie fest jeden
einzelnen Ausbruch will sie mit
Massentests und zwangsquarantäne
bekämpfen dabei ist das Land so weit
entfernt von der Null wie noch nie
Peking gleicht einer Geisterstadt
Schulen und Geschäfte sind geschlossen
Wohnungen werden zu Gefängnissen
mehr als ein Fünftel der chinesischen
Wirtschaft soll von lockdowns betroffen
sein nach drei Jahren corona-politik
haben viele keinen Job mehr
wir hoffen einfach dass es besser wird
wir brauchen nicht drüber zu sprechen
wie es den Menschen geht wir können ja
nicht mal unseren Lebensunterhalt
verdienen wenn es so weitergeht könnten
wir Probleme haben an Lebensmittel zu
kommen dann wird es richtig ernst
das Messezentrum im Norden der Stadt ist
inzwischen eine Quarantäne
Massenunterkunft in ganz China gibt es
32.000 neue coronafälle pro Tag bei 1,4
Milliarden Einwohnern andere Länder
würden sich über solche Zahlen freuen
hier ist es neuer Rekord
bitte gehen Sie nur raus wenn es absolut
notwendig ist die ansteckende
omicronvariante trifft eine Bevölkerung
in der bisher extrem wenige die
Krankheit durchgemacht haben und in der
vor allem von den Älteren zu wenige
geimpft sind
inhalierbare Impfstoffe die sollen jetzt
helfen doch Corona ist auch ein guter
Vorwand um die totale Kontrolle über das
chinesische Volk weiter auszubauen
dem Superman ging es am Ende wie allen
die sich trauen Kritik offen
auszusprechen er landete fast in Polizei
Gewahrsam die Menschenmenge schaffte es
in den Polizisten zu entreißen das ist
dabei bleibt und der chinesische Staat
riskiert dass er seinem Ärger noch
einmal Luft verschafft ist leider sehr
unwahrscheinlich
tja und die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
dieser Politik bekommen und nicht nur
die Chinesen zu spüren mit anderen
Nachrichten dieses Tages geht es jetzt
bei dir weiter Heinz Bundestag und
Bundesrat haben das Gesetz zum neuen
Bürgergeld verabschiedet es kommt zum
ersten Januar und ersetzt die
Hartz-IV-Regelung die wesentlichen
Punkte bürgergeldbezieher bekommen ab
Januar mehr Geld sie sollen besser als
bisher für eine dauerhafte Arbeit
qualifiziert werden das umstrittene
schon Vermögen wird erhöht 40.000 Euro
darf der eigentliche Leistungsbezieher
zunächst behalten Sanktionen greifen
weiterhin sofort
es gab noch andere wichtige
Entscheidungen im Bundesrat etwa für den
Weiterbetrieb der drei letzten
Atomkraftwerke bis Mitte April außerdem
kann die Reform des Wohngeldes mit einer
Erhöhung und mehr berechtigten Anfang
nächsten Jahres in Kraft treten und die
Vermieter müssen bei einer CO2-Abgabe
künftig mitbezahlen
der Bundestag hat den Bundeshaushalt für
2023 beschlossen vorgesehen sind
Ausgaben von rund 476 Milliarden Euro
und eine Neuverschuldung von knapp 46
Milliarden
bundesinnenministerin Felser will die
Hürden für Einbürgerungen herabsetzen
ihr Gesetzentwurf sieht zu dem Anreize
für Integration vor so kann schon nach
drei Jahren eingebürgert werden wer eine
besondere Integrationsleistung zeigt der
Regelfall sieht vor dass das Stadt wie
bisher nach acht schon nach fünf Jahren
Aufenthalt in Deutschland möglich ist
auch die Aufgabe der bisherigen
Staatsbürgerschaft soll nicht mehr
Voraussetzung sein für Menschen die
älter als 67 Jahre sind soll auch der
formelle Sprachnachweis entfallen
nach dem starken Anstieg der Migration
über das Mittelmeer hat die Europäische
Kommission die EU-Staaten zum mehr
Zusammenarbeit aufgerufen bei einem
Sondertreffen von Vertretern der
Innenministerien der EU-Länder ging es
auch darum den Streit über die Aufnahme
von Bootsflüchtlingen zu entschärfen
zuletzt hatte Frankreich ein
Rettungsschiff einer Hilfsorganisation
aufgenommen dem Italien die Einfahrt in
einen Hafen verweigert hatte
jahrelang waren die Zinsen niedrig und
die Baukosten noch im Normalbereich in
der Zeit hätte auch Vater Staat eifrig
bauen können das geschah aber nicht
zugleich haben viele Städte öffentliche
Baugrundstücke in begehrten Lagen gerne
versilbert die meist bietenden
Investoren die dann oh Wunder nicht in
erster Linie preiswerte Wohnungen Bauten
an denen mangelt ist in den
Ballungsgebieten bekanntlich gewaltig
und ist die neue Bundes-
[Musik]
ober Billwerder wird der heißen Hamburgs
105 der Stadtteil geplant mit
glücklichen Menschen die irgendwann auf
dieser feuchten Kuhweide im Osten der
Hansestadt leben die ersten 2030 Jahre
auch zu festgelegten sozialen mieten
danach können die Investoren mehr
verlangen wer auf soziales wohnen
angewiesen ist zieht weiter die Stadt
muss also noch eine Kuhweide mit
geförderten Wohnungen zu bauen von daher
brauche ich Lösung nachhaltige Lösung
Lösung die dafür sorgen dass
Steuergelder effizient eingesetzt werden
das heißt einmal gefördert immer günstig
und damit sparen wir auch enorme
ökologische Ressourcen ein zwei
Bürgerinitiativen überzeugten mit dieser
Idee erst genügend Wahlberechtigte und
damit dann zwangsläufig den Senat
mindestens 10% aller neu gebauten
Wohnungen der Stadt müssen demnach eine
Mietpreisbindung von 100 Jahren
beinhalten städtische Grundstücke werden
nach Möglichkeit nur noch vererbaurecht
vergeben und nicht mehr verkauft auch
das für 100 Jahre
bauen auf städtischem Grund der nur auf
Zeit verliehen ist erhöht aber meist die
Kreditzinsen wegen der fehlenden
Sicherheiten rechnet die Bauwirtschaft
vor
unsere Mitgliedsunternehmen benötigen
bei Bauprojekten in der Regel 20%
Eigenkapital 80% Fremdkapital wenn das
Fremdkapital nicht nur höheren Zinsen
unterliegt sondern auch noch durch
erbbaurechtgeschwächt wird dann ist das
für uns einfach schlecht und das führt
dazu dass weniger Bauprojekt der
entstehen werden App auch recht ist bei
uns wirklich gar nicht beliebt
tatsächlich hat die Stadt eine Hintertür
offen gehalten wenn öffentliches
Interesse besteht und das Parlament
zustimmt können städtische Grundstücke
sehr wohl verkauft werden dafür hat er
sie nach dem Gegenzug der langen
Mietpreisbindung zugestimmt die Aussicht
auf einen Volksentscheid hat einiges in
Gang gesetzt
wir gehen den Weg der kooperativen
Wohnungspolitik weiter aber dazu gehört
eben auch das auf man Belange der
Mietervereine reagiert deswegen war es
uns wichtig ein Konsens zu erzielen bei
einem Volksentscheid gegen die
Mietervereine wäre glaube ich für eine
SPD geführte Regierung keine gute Idee
Bund und Bundesländer finden es eine
gute Idee die Balance zwischen frei
finanziertem und sozialem Wohnungsbau zu
wahren das schien heute in Berlin eine
indirekte Absage also strikte Vorgaben
wie in Hamburg zu sein
dass uns das gemeinsame Ziel ein nicht
dass man in Deutschland wieder gut und
preiswert bauen können muss weil es gibt
einen großen Bedarf und das ist einer
der großen Herausforderungen für alle
staatlichen Ebenen Hamburgs
Herausforderung ist es jetzt
Förderprogramme aufzulegen die beides
bieten hundert Jahre sozialmiete und
private Förderung auch weil sich
Großprojekte wieder 150 Stadtteil ober
Billwerder ohne den Verkauf von
Grundstücken nicht finanzieren lassen
und dann kommt hinzu dass das Beheizen
der Wohnungen jetzt auch noch so teuer
wird plus die gestiegenen Strompreise
das bringt besonders jene in Not die eh
schon einen zu hohen Anteil ihres
Einkommens fürs Wohnen ausgeben die
preisbremsen für Gas Fernwärme und Strom
sollen das erheblich abmildern das
Kabinett hat das heute förmlich
beschlossen nächsten Monat geht es los
zunächst mit der Soforthilfe und danach
folgen die preisbremsen für Januar und
Februar allerdings rückwirkend märz wird
man deren Wirkung monatlich direkt sehen
wie das für die Verbraucher praktisch
funktionieren wird was Mieter und
Vermieter wissen müssen erklärt
eine Szene die sich gerade überall in
Deutschlands Kellern zuträgt die Preise
für Gas Strom und Fernwärme steigen und
steigen die Bundesregierung will diese
Preiserhöhungen mit Preis Bremsen bis
April 2024 verlangsamen
dazu setzt sie jeweils am Abschlag an
bei den regelmäßigen Vorauszahlungen an
den Strom Gas oder fernwärmeversorger
die Versorger müssen neue Abschläge
ermitteln
vor allem für alle Haushaltskunden
dienen direkten Vertrag mit einem
Gasversorger haben für die ist am
einfachsten die müssen sich um nichts
kümmern die sollten höchstens zur
Sicherheit nachschauen ob und wie die
Erstattung erfolgt ist sollten sich die
Information des versorges anschauen das
ist ganz klar bisschen komplizierter
wird es für die Mieter werden weil da
die Regelungen noch nicht eindeutig sind
aber ja in der Summe ist das System wie
es jetzt geplant ist wohl das was in der
aktuellen Situation machbar war
beim Gas und bei der Fernwärme gibt es
die Preisbremse in zwei Schritten zuerst
kommt die Soforthilfe die Gas- und
fernwärmekundenzahlen einfach keinen
Dezember Abschlag Mieter die ihre
Abschläge an den Vermieter zahlen
bekommen die Soforthilfe erst über ihre
nächste Jahresabrechnung
die zweite Stufe der Gas und
fernwärmepreisbremse läuft wiederum über
den Abschlag so die Pläne der Versorger
verringert den aktuellen hohen Abschlag
denn die Kunden und Kunden müssen auf
die ersten 80% ihres Verbrauchs nur den
staatlich festgelegten Preis von 12 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde zahlen dabei wird in
der Regel auf Basis des Verbrauchs im
Jahr 2021 gerechnet lediglich für die
restlichen 20% wird der hohe aktuelle
Preis berechnet deswegen lohnt sich
Energiesparen nach wie vor in der
zweiten Stufe sondern auch die Vermieter
den Abschlag zeitnah anpassen den
größten Aufwand aber haben die Versorger
das ist für die Energieversorger machbar
da müssen im Einzelfall noch Sachen
geklärt werden aber wenn die Preis
Bremsen im März starten und dann
rückwirkend die Entlastung für Januar
und Februar kommt dann ist das umsetzbar
für die Energieversorger wir sprechen
hier über einen Massenmarkt 20 Millionen
Gasverträge 40 Millionen Stromverträge
die müssen angepasst werden
die anderen preisbremsen funktionieren
ähnlich nur mit anderen Preisen bei der
Fernwärme gilt ein staatlicher Preis von
9,5 Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim Strom
liegt der festgelegte Preis bei 40 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde diese Zahlen gelten
für private Haushalte und kleinere
Betriebe für die Industrie und andere
Großverbraucher gelten eigene Werte
für alle Verbraucher gilt jetzt schauen
Sie sich Ihre Abschlagszahlungen an die
sollten im Frühjahr sinken wenn Sie per
Dauerauftrag zahlen sollten Sie diesen
anpassen die Versorger wiederum werden
für die Preisnachlässe mit Milliarden
vom Staat entschädigt
sehr hohe Heizkosten hohe Spritkosten
Inflation stellt sich natürlich immer
die Frage wie sehr das die Wirtschaft
abbremst heißt damit geht es bei euch
jetzt weiter ja da schauen wir auf die
Konsumlaune der Verbraucher in diesen
Tagen von Schnäppchenjagd bis
Weihnachtsgeschäft mit welchen
Erwartungen schaut der Handel auf diese
Tage und Wochen Frank Mettmann ja mit
sehr hohen und das trotz aller erwähnten
Widerstände das hängt auch mit dem
heutigen Black Friday zusammen diese
groß angelegte Rabattaktion soll die
Verbraucher zum Shoppen animieren und
das belegen Umfragen wie die das
Ifo-Instituts funktioniert viele Kunden
sein wegen der hohen Inflationsraten auf
der Suche nach Schnäppchen heißt es da
dass die Krise den Black Friday
beflügelt davon geht auch der
Einzelhandel aus wir erwarten dieses
Jahr sogar ein Plus von über 20 Prozent
auf 5,7 Milliarden Euro Umsatz gerade
jetzt suchen die Kundinnen Kunden
Angebote nutzen diese Möglichkeit
sollten aber auch genau hinschauen
CHECK24 hat die Preise von einer halben
Millionen Artikel aus dem Vorjahr
verglichen nur gut die Hälfte war am
Black Friday tatsächlich billiger als im
Vormonat am günstigsten damals Office
Monitore Soundbars und Wassersprudler
Manchester gegen sogar teurer besonders
Staubsaugerroboter Fitness Tracker oder
Küchengeräte Zubehör trotz aller
Erwartungen die der Einzelhandel mit
dieser großen Aktion verbindet die
Sorgen bleiben nämlich dass das
Weihnachtsgeschäft dann im Dezember
schlechter ausfallen könnte weil sich
viele eben jetzt schon mit den
Geschenken eingedeckt haben Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
bei der
weltartenschutzkonferenz sieht es in
Panama sind heute weitreichende
Entscheidungen getroffen worden mit
handelsverboten gegen das Artensterben
haben Vertreter von 184 Staaten nach
mehrtägigen Beratungen unter anderem ein
Schutzpaket für fast an 100 high und
Rochenarten bestätigt ein Durchbruch
laut Umweltschützern
zur Fußball-WM da steht für Gastgeber
Kata schon das frühzeitige ausfest in
Gruppe A verlor Kata heute gegen Senegal
1 zu 3 und die Niederlande und Ecuador
trennten sich unentschieden eins zu eins
in Gruppe B hat Wales 0:2 gegen Iran
verloren und England USA gegen
Unentschieden aus 0 0
anzensberger ist eine der Namen die
einem sofort einfallen wenn von den
sogenannten führenden Intellektuellen
des Landes die Rede ist von denen gab es
im Nachkriegsdeutschland einige sie
waren meist weniger Spezialisten auf
diesem oder jenem Gebiet sondern vielen
eher in die Kategorie Dichter und Denker
manchmal noch Philosophen im ganzen Land
bekannt politisch mehr oder weniger
verortet streitfreudig und umstritten
hoch und breit gebildet immer eloquent
und robust in Diskurs eine Generation
für sich die meisten inzwischen
gestorben nun also auch Enzensberger
und es fällt nicht leicht zu sagen wer
eigentlich ihre Nachfolger oder
Nachfolgerinnen sind es waren vielleicht
auch andere Zeiten in einer Gesellschaft
die sich neu formierte und aufbaut
Christian von Rechenberg erinnert an
Hans Magnus Enzensberger
wie nähert man sich einem der ausweicht
der sich wandelt der von sich selbst
rückblickend sagt ich war einmal
Chefideologe
ich war mal Renegat ich war
Individualist des schreiben halt
Journalisten voneinander ab da kann man
nichts dagegen machen
Hans Magnus Enzensberger universal
Gelehrter universalkritiker einer der
stört weil er aufschreibt was im Land
passiert seine Sicht der Dinge ist
kosmopolitisch und provokant
1957 blutrot Verteidigung der Wölfe kaum
ein Schüler jener Zeit der solche Zeilen
nicht verdauen durfte ließ keine Oden
mein Sohn lies die Fahrpläne die sind
genau das ist nicht die Sprache des
überkommenen deutschen Dichters und
Denkers das ist Rock n Roll die Gruppe
47 und Günther Gras und Ingeborg
Bachmann feiert den jungen zornigen Mann
den Büchner Preisträger mit der feinen
Nase für Veränderung die früh wittert
dass die Zeit der Gruppe 47 abläuft
zum Anlass das zu schreiben es ist doch
nur ein Verein eine irgendeine klicke
Metamorphose als die 68er auf die Straße
gehen ist ensons Berger der Star einer
von ihnen debattieren reicht nicht er
will machen Antifaschist nicht der
Ideologie wegen sondern aus Gewissheit
Demokraten helfen nur Soldaten das ist
auf den alten historischen Kern gebracht
der Inhalt der Notstandsverfassung hält
der Gegenkultur auf Zeit als Genosse
tauge er nicht sagte er über sich selbst
und gründet das Leitmedium der Linken
Intelligenz das Kursbuch
das war eigentlich so ein eine Art
zivilisationsprojekt dann musste dieses
Land ein bisschen ziviler machen so war
die Idee etwas verändern mit Worten und
Gedanken stets begleitet vom Zweifel an
deren Wirkung so vermessen wäre ich auch
gern
so nützlich so rücksichtslos hilfreich
wie die Müllabfuhr
Metamorphose in den 80ern und 90ern
orientiert sich Enzensberger neu hin zum
intellektuellen Bürgertum er verdient
sich als Herausgeber von Zeitschriften
und Buchheim bleibt scharfsinnig jedoch
nur
kragenplatz oder also es muss ein
starker Antrieb dafür sein die EU etwa
treibt ihn an die er zum Politbüro
degradiert und Edward Snowden adelt er
zum Helden
ihn selbst adeln zahllose Preise und
Auszeichnungen ihn der stets gut war für
Überraschungen danke mag man ihm zurufen
für den scharfen Blick für Kurs und
Gegenkurs und wundervolle Verse
[Musik]
das war's von uns und es geht direkt
weiter mit dem neuen ZDF politbarometer-
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer der Weg für das
Bürgergeld ist frei nach langen Streit
ging alles auf einmal ganz schnell
Ampelkoalition und Union einigten sich
diese Woche alle waren zufrieden
Bundestag und heute auch der Bundesrat
haben zugestimmt dabei hat die Union
durchgesetzt dass anders als von der
Ampel geplant von Anfang an Sanktionen
drohen wenn Empfänger von Bürgergeld
ihre Mitwirkungspflichten verletzen
das ist nun doch strengere Sanktionen
gibt finden fast drei Viertel der
Befragten gut 21 Prozent finden es nicht
gut
Mehrheiten dafür gibt es bei den
Anhängern aller im Bundestag vertretenen
Parteien
zum ersten Januar bekommen die knapp
fünf Millionen Leistungsbezieher auch
mehr Geld die geplante Erhöhung des
Regelsatzes um 53 Euro findet knapp die
Hälfte der Befragten richtig gut ein
Viertel meint es sollte noch mehr sein
das Verständnis für die
Leistungserhöhung ist also groß
schließlich spüren viele Menschen die
steigenden Kosten am eigenen Leib
für mehr als jeden zweiten Befragten ist
der Preisanstieg in vielen Bereichen des
Lebens ein großes Problem 45 Prozent
sehen das nicht so über zwei Drittel der
Deutschen geben an zu Hause stark
Energie zu sparen 30 Prozent tun das
nicht
die Regierungskoalition hat nach Ansicht
der Befragten im Politbarometer in der
letzten Zeit kein harmonisches Bild
abgegeben eine Mehrheit findet dass das
Verhältnis zwischen den
Koalitionspartnern eher schlecht ist wie
wirkt sich das aus wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD weiter
auf 19 Prozent
cdu/csu 28 die Grünen 22 die FDP fünf
Prozent alle unverändert AFD 14 Prozent
minus 1 Die Linke 6 Prozent plus 1
damit hätte die amtierende Ampel weiter
keine parlamentarische Mehrheit mehr
reichen würde es aber für Schwarz-Grün
auf unserer Liste der wichtigsten
Politiker die die Befragten selbst
bestimmen gibt es nur wenig Bewegung auf
der Skala von +5-5 bewertet nach
Sympathie und Leistung bleibt Alice
Weidel Schlusslicht minus 2,9 deutlich
schlechter und weit im negativbereich
davor Sarah Wagenknecht minus 0,8 Platz
8 Christine Lambrecht -0,5 vor ihr
Friedrich Merz - 0,4 alle drei
unverändert Platz sechs Christian
Lindner - 0,3 etwas schlechter Markus
Söder auf Platz 5 - 0,1 leicht
verbessert Karl Lauterbach 0,0 etwas
schlechter Platz 3 für Olaf Scholz 0,4
leichte Verluste und sein bisher
schlechtester Wert im Politbarometer
davor Robert Habeck 0,8 auch er etwas
schlechter und knapp davor auf Platz 1
Annalena beerburg 0,8 auch sie mit
Verlusten
kontaktbeschränkungen abgesagte
Weihnachtsmärkte im letzten Jahr waren
die coronazahlen hoch die Maßnahmen aus
Sorge vor einem harten corona-winter
streng und heute
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach warnt vor
der nächsten winterwelle doch aktuell
sinken die Infektionszahlen und mit
ihnen auch die Zahl derer die sich wegen
Corona um ihre Gesundheit sorgen auf
jetzt nur noch 30%
das Auslaufen sämtlicher
corona-maßnahmen wird diskutiert mehrere
Bundesländer haben die isolationspflicht
für corona-infizierte aufgehoben das
stößt bei den meisten Befragten auf
Ablehnung
62% finden es sollte für Corona
infizierte weiterhin eine
isolationspflicht geben 35 Prozent sind
nicht dieser Meinung
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Umweltsünden
Diskriminierung von Minderheiten es gibt
viel Kritik an der WM in Katar nicht
genug findet fast jeder zweite
14 Prozent halten die Kritik an dem
Wüstenstaat wegen der Verletzung von
Menschenrechten für übertrieben 49
Prozent aber sind der Meinung sie müsste
härter ausfallen knapp ein Drittel
findet es gut so wie es ist
das Auftaktspiel gegen Japan hat das
deutsche Team verloren sportlich gesehen
halten sich die Erwartungen an die
Nationalmannschaft in Grenzen
nur sechs Prozent sind überzeugt dass
Deutschland Fußballweltmeister wird mehr
als Dreiviertel aber glauben nicht dass
die Mannschaft den Titel holen wird
kein WM-Fieber also aus vielen Gründen
am Sonntag hat Deutschland das nächste
Vorrundenspiel der Gegner heißt dann
Spanien falls ein kleines Fußballwunder
geschieht und die deutsche Elf gewinnt
könnte die Hoffnung auf den Titel
natürlich wieder steigen
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF textabseite 165 in
der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF heute.de
wie ich die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen zustande kommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
Politbarometer Punkt zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
16 Dezember nach dem Wetter geht es hier
gleich weiter mit der heute-show Ihnen
noch ein entspannten Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses erste
Adventswochenende wird ruhig und das
liegt ein gleich zwei Hochs dem Hoch
Erik und dem hochflorian dass sich
nämlich von Südwesten zu uns reinschiebt
über dem Mittelmeer braut sich gerade
wieder ein Unwetter tief zusammen da gab
es ja schon kräftige Windböen und auch
viel Regen das wird jetzt am Wochenende
wieder der Fall sein auch bei uns fällt
etwas Regen aber deutlich weniger
zwischen der Ostseeküste und dem
Alpenrand in dieser Nacht da reicht
vielleicht auch noch mal für etwas
Schneeregen im Westen ist es dagegen
trocken zum Teil auch klar und die
Temperaturen sinken auf sechs Grad an
der Nordsee und bis ein Grad an der
Mosel oder auch am alten Rand die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen fünf Grad in der Oberpfalz und
maximal 11 Grad am Rhein und morgen
Vormittag kann es auch noch ein bisschen
regnen vorübergehend hier in Ostsachsen
oder auch in Niederbayern sonst wird das
ein freundlicher November Sonnabend hin
und wieder durchaus auch mit
Sonnenschein besonders Richtung Rhein
und an der Nordseeküste der Sonntag
bringt dann wohl mehr Nebel hin wieder
aber auch strahlende Sonnenschein wie
hier am Alpenrand bei Temperaturen von
vier bis zehn Grad zum späten Nachmittag
und Abend allerdings werden dann die
Wolken hier von Nordwesten dichter und
bringen Regen mit und ähnlich
wechselhaft startet dann auch die neue
Woche dabei bleibt es zunächst noch mild
bei Temperaturen von 1 bis 10 Grad aber
von Osten wird es kälter und das macht
sich dann so bemerkbar dass zum Ende der
Woche diese Kälte auch Frankreich
erreicht haben wird schönes Wochenende